the green knight seems just about as
far-fetched as a movie can be
fortunately it's also one of the most
interesting upcoming big screen
offerings out there
its first trailer has dropped and it
makes clear that fans are right to
expect great things
let's take a moment to break it down the
teaser opens with the knights of the
round table in camelot and their ruler
king arthur requests entertainment for
himself and his queen in a textbook case
of be careful what you ask for
a monstrous green knight who looks like
he's made out of wood steps in
and challenges a knight to take a free
shot at him the young sir gawain played
by dev patel
is quick to accept the challenge and
decapitates the strange visitor it's at
this point that the green knight picks
up his head and proclaims
one yeah hence
as the rest of the trailer makes clear
this means gawain must meet the monster
in a year to complete the game and
receive a blow in turn
it's pretty clear that the green knight
enters the castle with full knowledge
that he was setting his opponent up not
least because he delivers a
pitch-perfect evil laugh as he flees in
full headless horseman mode while gawain
might be concerned with the fact that
his days are numbered the trailer makes
sure that the viewer can't help but
wonder exactly what the green knight is
all about the year has almost passed and
gawain seems intent on setting the whole
green knight incident aside however his
king doesn't want to hear any of it in a
meeting between gawain and arthur the
ruler states in fairly clear terms that
gowan must find the green knight to
fulfill his pact and just like that a
quest is given
because the green knight survived
gawain's blow and the mythical king of
britons turns out to be a completionist
the young knight has no choice but to
leave the confines of arthur's
stronghold and travel through a land
that's unlike anything he's seen before
it's a solid and ominous start for an
epic adventure
as sir gawain rides toward an
unfortunate fate a creepy voice
speaks ill of his chances for survival
it's easy to assume that the raspy
whisper belongs to a soothsayer
or witch of some sort but the source of
these pessimistic predictions turns out
to be an otherwise perfectly cute and
furry fox that for some reason chooses
to hang out with gawain it appears that
whatever fate awaits the young knight
the fox isn't particularly happy about
it
why do you stop me
since the very next thing we see is
gawain swinging his axe at the camera
and the shot looks a whole lot like it
might be from the fox's point of view
it's unclear if the fox is trying to
warn the knight of a threat or
making one either way a talking fox
seems like a pretty cool creature in the
movie's heavy fantasy setting
and we can only hope that it won't meet
its doom
the green knight is a pretty
star-studded production and the trailer
features all sorts of legendary
characters and amazing creatures even so
one of its most threatening figures
seems to be entirely human though not
any less dangerous for it right after
the fox has given its warnings and
gawain swings his axe the trailer
introduces the scavenger this character
is a bandit who manages to tie gawain up
and steal his massive weapon
the fact that the scavenger and his men
manage to defeat a knight of the round
table is one thing the fact that he
appears to be aware of gawain's quest
takes things to a completely different
level
sir gawain climbs a hill he observes a
misty vista
over which a group of gigantic shadowy
figures slowly march toward an
unknown destination gawain doesn't seem
awfully surprised or shocked to see them
and in the very next moment he lifts his
axe and appears to scream triumphantly
it creates the impression that gawain
has been actively seeking out these
giants or
at least knows what they are and is very
pleased to witness their travels in
person
eagle-eyed viewers will also note that
the fox from earlier seems to be by his
side
as such there's a chance that whatever
happens between the two in the forest
earlier in the trailer the fox survives
the meeting to annoy gawain even further
as befits the trailer's general air of
mystery the nature of the giants remains
very much up in the air though their
introductory shot shows them just
wandering
a later one shows one of them reaching
for gawain did the knight intend to seek
them out or did he just stumble in their
dangerous path
this remains to be seen
a casual viewing of the trailer might
give you the impression that it gives
away a whole lot of the plot of the
green knight however the moments near
the end make it clear that the trailer
only barely scratches the surface
the movie has plenty of big name actors
that we barely see in the trailer
for instance joel edgerton's lord alicia
vikander's lady
and aaron kellyman's winfred toward the
end of the trailer we see a succession
of quick adequately mysterious shots
featuring several of the hitherto unseen
characters
lord in particular gets a quick
shirtless scene and later returns to ask
awayne what he hopes to gain from his
mission gawain seems to have come
a long way from the opening moments of
the trailer since his answer is clear
and devoid of his earlier hesitancy he
declares that he does his work for honor
because that is why knight does what he
does
the trailer ends in pretty much the only
way it can as the last words of his
heroic reply to the lord linger we see
gawain enter some sort of wooded area in
which nature seems to have taken over
the green knight awaits within walking
down a set of stairs to meet gawain and
asks if the knight is ready
this fortunately isn't even close to a
spoiler though the trailer offers a
series of short exciting glimpses into
the movie's world
it does a commendable job at not
revealing anything beyond the most
general outline of the plot there are
still many entirely unexplained moments
such as the halo crown and the
inexplicable scene that features
gawain's head seemingly catching fire
all in all it seems that while the green
knight trailer gives glimpses of some of
the film secrets it has also hinted at
even greater and deeper ones that you
can't
possibly hope to comprehend without
seeing the movie that's the sign of a
pretty great trailer
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the green knight are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]